more than a dozen US cities have ordered
nighttime curfews as protests rage over
the death of a black man in police
custody curfews are enforced right now
in Los Angeles Philadelphia and Atlanta
among others the unrest has been
escalating across the country as
demonstrators took to the streets for
the fifth day running they're demanding
justice for George Floyd and an end to
police violence against minorities while
many of the protests have been peaceful
some demonstrators have sent police cars
on fire and there have been incidents of
looting in Minneapolis where the
protests began police have masked in
large numbers and deployed tear gas and
rubber bullets to clear demonstrators
breaking an 8 p.m. curfew let's talk now
to DW correspondent Stefon Simmons who
is on the streets of Minneapolis Stefon
so now that there is a curfew in place
what is the situation where you are
right now it is eerily quiet
I have to say ground zero for very
violent and not so violent protests who
in the last week is entirely quiet down
the curfew Wars and first with police
rather determined with the help of the
National Guard whether determined to let
not happen anymore what had going down
here the last few nights in the last few
days with buildings burning and
protesters or rioters in that case
looting and ransacking buildings and
stores and private houses even so we
could actually say that what happened
today is what happened to this car in
the back that any effort of any rioters
to set more buildings ablaze were
crashing into a determined police force
who took no prisoners in terms of using
all the tools they had at their disposal
beanbags teargas
and anything else they needed to
disperse the crowd here zone by zone
protected by the National Guard who set
up protective perimeters in which the
police then could move in and remove and
disburse protesters all right so it is
quiet now but we know that earlier this
evening you actually had your own
confrontation with the police let's have
a look at the video you sent us yes we
are we're doing a job and this is the
Senate Senate presentation so come on
where would you like us to go okay
Thank You officer all right Stefan well
that does appear to be a rather tense
situation but overall how would you
characterize police conduct in
Minneapolis well I would say they did
their job today at least as outlined by
their superior slash politicians
governor of the state as well as the
municipal government here remember they
didn't show up the last three days
before today or nights just yesterday we
had a curfew installed here too but
there was no police had no National
Guard actually even close to be able or
willing to enforce this and this has
changed today conduct as you can see in
this scene where my cameraman max Fergie
and I had this encounter just a little
bit of context three police cars had
actually encircled another TV production
team we don't know from what Network and
as we do in the field here we then rush
there and try to document this not to
interfere but document this and as you
saw nerves were a little bit frazzled
there I can somewhat understand this
because those those policemen are under
a lot of stress doing their job but of
course they should have let us work and
do our job but you know what did you
you're not I was or we were not about to
pick a fight tonight
all right Stefan Siemens reporting from
Minneapolis we appreciate it
well George Floyd's death has also
sparked demonstrations internationally
including here in the German capital
hundreds rallied in front of the US
Embassy in Berlin in solidarity several
groups had called for the rally on
social media under the motto justice for
George Floyd against racist police
violence
and just a few miles away graffiti of
Floyd was painted onto a section of the
Berlin wall together with the caption I
can't breathe for more let's talk to
Diana RC she's a Berlin based artist and
activist and also the founder of the
anti racism empowerment project white
guilt clean up Diana thank you so much
for joining us so what relevance does
the death of George Floyd have to people
outside the United States and especially
here in Germany hi good morning yeah I
think for black Germans particularly or
any black people any black tiles for
people who are living in Germany it's
just a sign of what is happening it's a
sign of what's to come in Germany if
Germany consider continues on the course
that they're currently on the United
Nations had put out a report what I
think two years ago and stated made some
very very clear statements about how
German laws do not do enough to protect
black people within the within the
borders of Germany all right well what
can you tell us about how people
currently are organizing in Berlin to
support people of color well I can't
speak too much to how people are
organizing to support people of color I
I work primarily in grassroots
organizing for supporting black people
and there's a lot of different things
going on there are several
collaborations and coalition's that have
been putting - being put together one of
the biggest issues that we have here in
Germany is that of aggregated statistic
racial statistics for police violence
aggregated racist statistics for
incarceration for dust in custody
none of this stuff is actually available
so several different groups have been
putting this to get together and working
on this like reach out and cop and there
are several big campaigns that have been
being supported for a very long time
that have started in the last years
including a banned racial profile
because now racial profiling is legal
and is legal in Berlin and each one
teach one has actually started this year
an afro census where they are asking
black diasporic people in Germany to
fill out a census so we can have a
better overview of what is really the
black experience in Germany well with
all of these demonstrations in the
United States across that country
outside the US do you see this enormous
response to George Floyd's death in
police custody somehow a kind of turning
point no not at all
I think one of the issues in Germany in
particular is that white anti-racist
activists feel that they need to come
and speak every time there is a deaths
or a murder in the United States but
there have been plenty of murders in
Germany plenty of deaths in custody that
have not been solved or a giallo
in 2008 2005 still has not been solved
he died in police custody and
mecklenburg-vorpommern the state in
which this occurred actually never the
state last year I believe it was last
year the year before last year the year
before they actually on the last day of
Black History Month decided not to
continue investigating this particular
case of this black man who died in
police custody in 2005 and and so for us
it's the thing of we see we see white
activist we see German activist come out
and speak about what is going on in the
United States in a very us centric way
without really acknowledging the
problems that are happening here in
Germany and how dangerous it is for germ
for black black diasporic people
including black Germans to exist inside
of Germany all right Diana
RC Berlin based artist and activist we
appreciate all your insights
thank you